suspense
no oh my gosh seriously right oh whoa
you're so handsome
Chris fix is the largest Automotive
Channel on YouTube with nearly 10
million subscribers teaching people how
to fix their cars however most people
have no idea who he actually is and he's
never agreed to do a podcast until now
this is my first podcast ever so here's
the entire story of chrisfix and trust
me it is not what you'd expect oh by the
way if you enjoy episodes like this make
sure to subscribe because we post brand
new episodes every single week thank you
guys so much and now let's begin hey
guys Chris Vicks here with the Graham
Stefan show what's going on what's up
it's so weird seeing you here but like
hearing your voice because I've seen
your videos before you've never shown
your face on the videos and you've never
done podcasts before never this is my
first podcast ever that's crazy thank
you so much for doing this and also we
got the I believe you're the largest
Automotive Channel on YouTube yeah yeah
10 million subscribers just under 10
million hopefully hit 10 million next
year and uh wow you know it's at the end
of the day it's just a number it's just
cool how many people hearing that number
how many people I'm able to help you
know so there's people who are
interested enough to uh to subscribe and
join and watch my videos every month you
know yeah and that's also 10 years on
YouTube right yeah well so the beginning
wasn't really it was me making fishing
videos and having a good time with my
friends and like putting me hitting
waves on a boat to the music like so it
wasn't always like this it was just when
I got my first car I wanted to learn how
to fix cars so I wasn't reliant on
somebody else and also I saw what like
mechanics did to my parents when they
brought a car in and so I was like why
not let me be reliant on myself let me
learn these skills and uh pick them up
from different places from my dad he
would teach me how to change brakes uh
my dad's friends mechanics that are in
the family or that we're friends with
um and I just go from there and learn as
much as I can tinkering is huge once you
know the basics you could okay I just
need to remove this bolt you know a
certain size socket fits on there you
remove it and you could break things
down put things together it's pretty
Bare Bones yeah simple you know Macy's
um Audi was out of uh AC fluid and it
was YouTube that taught me how to refill
that incredibly easy like you don't even
need to take it into a shop to refill
air conditioner fluid or the freon yeah
it's so easy to do and it was like crazy
video though yeah you had to pull the my
refrigerant video so then you could see
always wear gloves you know eye
protection so you don't hurt yourself or
any protection uh yeah so I guess
everything was gonna blow off in my face
I'm always super cool what happens if
like this just explodes I'm dead my
hand's gone yeah yeah I'm always just
I'm super careful because I want to
teach people how to be careful so it's
like they don't get hurt doing this
because a trip to the hospital is going
to cost you a lot more than saving you
know a thousand bucks yeah are you ever
worried about liability if you
have a video teaching someone how to do
something and they screw it up or they
get hurt like has that ever come back to
you oh it's never come back to me um I
think I am very thorough I mean there's
always the disclaimers in the
description I think people know going on
YouTube and doing it yourself like
you're taking that risk yourself you're
Gathering that information uh you know
I'm not licensed or anything I'm not
showing people hey this is how you do it
uh as a licensed technician you know you
have to follow this method I don't it
doesn't cost you know it's free for the
public to use as an educational piece so
I've never really had that concern and
I'm also super super thorough and uh I
always cover like I just right away I
just talked about oh yeah the first
thing I did was like safety goggles and
and gloves for protection because right
away I think okay that refrigerant could
be cold you know and it could cause you
frostbite or could shoot out at you
um which you know you also learn from
experience that that happens yeah
um so I'm not really concerned about
that no and I also I forget I don't care
about well I shouldn't say I don't care
but I'm less concerned about the
liability as much as I don't want my
viewers to get hurt like they're all
very important to me so I want to make
sure I teach them the right way to do it
that way they are smart about it you
always hear okay use the the respirator
and you'll see people like oh you don't
need to use a respirator I'm like it's a
good idea you're working on you know
sanding anytime you sand you should use
a respirator even though like not
everybody in this in the industry will
do that let's start here I'm sure the
viewers are going to wonder about the
helmet sure no one's seen your face it's
so you're probably watching you're like
okay this is a little weird and I get it
but you have to understand there's two
things one my videos are all about
teaching you guys how to fix your cars
so if you are learning how to fix your
car you don't need to worry about me
like I'm not important and I was never
in my mind I'm never important it's the
information that's important that's why
I spend you know a week before I make a
video Gathering as much information
going out and learning about okay this
individual car how is this done okay how
about this car and what are people
people going to run into so it's it's
not like it's about me at all it's
always about here's what we're doing and
I'll be completely honest with you I
never thought about turning the camera
around
so like I know it sounds weird it was
like I look back and I think back is
never come to my mind to be like oh let
me film this way because if I'm talking
about breaks I'm filming the brakes but
do you think that's maybe a 10 years ago
thing like when you first started
fewer people were vlogging like I was
good friends with uh Gordon f-spot and
up until recently he's never showed his
face I'm like dude you gotta show your
face because he started around the same
time as uh we're just like it's just
after James the strad man okay and
stratman's channel just blew up yeah but
I think a lot of that was that
connection of just like showing his face
and like who he is as a person versus
just filming from behind a camera for
sure there's there's connections people
make in different ways I think the
connection people make to me is not as a
uh it's not me in my personality as much
as they're able to get their car fixed
because of me so I was just at SEMA
that's why my voice sounds a little
weird I've been doing demonstrations all
week talking to thousands of fans it's
incredible and anytime I talk to those
fans it wasn't like hey your YouTube
videos are so entertaining they're so
you made me laugh and there's nothing
wrong with people who make people laugh
or entertain people at all it was hey
you changed my life because I learned
how to fix cars uh I'm now super
interested in cars or I I don't like
working on cars by I was concerned if I
go to a mechanic they'd rip me off but I
learned from your videos like what they
said was accurate or I was able to speak
smartly about it it's my new hobby I
became a technician all I I was able to
get to work and not get fired you know I
couldn't afford to change my brakes but
you know I was able to through your
videos and and now I can get to work and
not get fired it's all positive things
like that yeah and it's less because of
you know what's behind here and more
because of what you see in front of you
yeah so when you go in public do you
wear you don't wear the helmet you don't
wear the whole apparatus right like you
you'll show your face and yeah so at
SEMA for example I will sometimes walk
around with this on it seema's very car
oriented so I'd say about like 75
percent of the people there know me so
and there's a lot of people and there's
a lot of cameras so I'll walk around
wearing the helmet when I do my
demonstrations or whatever I wear my
helmet I got um I was a nominee for
influencer of the year uh through SEMA
and you know to the dinner I work shirt
tie and I have my helmet but during the
dinner it's like fancy you know yeah
during the dinner I put my helmet under
the table nobody knew who I am because I
don't have any there's none of this on
me there's there's no hat there's I just
don't know who I am just my friends like
Adam you know what knows who I am and uh
TJ hunt they know who I am nobody else
does they're not going to take pictures
so you know try to expose me so I just
take the helmet off nobody knows if I
win put the helmet on walk up on stage
but but let's say that some of the cars
you drive might be recognizable maybe in
the area you live in or have you ever
had it where people like Snap pictures
or videos and be like you're the guy
driving that car you wanna know what I
don't know if it's just luck or if it's
really my fans my fans are pretty
respectable like I've gotten pictures
taken and they blur the license plate
for me and not everybody knows how to do
that you know right so it takes like
extra effort to do that and they'll blur
license plates this my face is a little
too exposed through the glass so they'll
they'll lightly darken the glass or blur
the glass
um maybe that's some that's keeping some
of them mystery alive like they want to
be the ones to say hey I saw it but you
can't but you just saw it exactly I get
questions like that hey can I get a
picture without the mess just for me you
know I'm like there's too much risk
involved in that I work pretty hard at
keeping it secret on purpose and so
that's that's the one aspect again
there's two aspects the one aspect is
hey it's not about me it never was about
me and even that 10 million subscribers
I still tried not to keep it about me
which is probably why I've never done a
podcast
um but uh I I like to to just keep it
about the work that's getting done and
the next thing is my friend so at SEMA I
took my race team yeah I was very
fortunate to bring him out and we do the
lemons race and my best friend Garrett
took me out to dinner I was like an
appreciation thank you we went to a nice
Wolfgang Puck restaurant he was so
excited like all the stakes are great
here and I wore none of my my swag
normally like this is my this and khakis
is my uniform this is why I wear every
day yeah like a Steve Jobs thing where I
you should see my my closet it's this
merch yeah this I had the college shirt
on I had nice pants you know and and
nothing on me except that and nobody
knew who I was but even if you're in
your hometown and you're going out
wearing just a Chris thick shirt it just
doesn't like it never happens where
people try to Snap photos or anything no
you know everybody's really respectful
one person tried to do that and they
told them what are you doing what the
heck are you doing you know and uh my
fans are great like I I'm incredible
yeah because my viewers are like like me
it's not about the Famer I think they
just want to learn how to fix their car
they just want to enjoy the car
community so
yeah I mean eventually I'm sure somebody
will try but I do my best to like be
reasonable and and hopefully they
respect it and all you could do do you
think one day you'll do a face reveal
like dream did maybe 10 million
subscribers I might have something kind
of planned we'll see it's really
incredible occasion to be like at 10
million subscribers like that's a that's
an unfathomable number like like yeah
but you're getting there you're
incredibly yeah you're very close yeah
yeah I feel like you could get there
within a month or two if you just posted
a few shorts But first you want to thank
our sponsor vid IQ guys we have all been
using vid IQ on our channels for
literally years now and it's hard to put
into words just how tremendously helpful
it's been for our growth as creators
think about good the YouTube algorithm
is in matching the right content with
the right person and then imagine having
access to all of those tools to help
make better videos well that's exactly
what her sponsor vid IQ has allowed us
to do vid IQ is a powerful tool that
allows creators like us to get real-time
analytics and data and not just on our
videos but on trending videos and topic
ideas that are outperforming our own
vidiq uses an advanced AI that helps
provide additional video suggestions and
ideas that sometimes are much different
than what we had in mind this includes
finding which keywords are trending in
the video titles and showing you not
only how many people searched up each
keyword but how many creators are making
content about it already plus you could
sign up for the low cost of just a
dollar
that's right just one dollar that's it
you can get super computer-like data
helping you grow and perfectly optimize
your video content start making the most
optimized content possible and take your
video performance to the next level by
using the link Down Below in the
description and signing up and now with
that said let's get back to the podcast
I think it would be cool to talk about
because you started YouTube I know you
didn't say technically 10 years ago
right yeah but like where you were in
the beginning of your YouTube career
because now you're doing it full time
yeah and uh and how you basically ramped
that up until now and when you realize
you could probably do it as a business
yeah like what were you doing before
YouTube okay this is gonna be an
interesting story I don't think anybody
really knows this so this is a first but
I started I love fishing in Marine
Biology and the ocean oh that's why you
like The Reef that's what I like that
that's so cool yeah so uh that I
actually became a rainbow just Bells
I'll start like back a little bit more
so I wanted to go to this marine biology
high school it's like uh out by me they
do these specialized high schools almost
like vocational schools but for stuff
that's not necessarily technically
technical like it's not like auto
mechanics and hairdressers and HVAC it's
like marine biology and biotech and
pre-med and computer science I wanted to
go to the Marine Biology one and I
missed it by one person so they only
accepted like 30 people and I was number
31. my parents pushed so hard they talk
to politicians I was able to go in the
next year of high school but I ended up
getting into the culinary version of it
in my school like near my house and uh I
was like what the heck I could cook fish
you know I always take that if there's
an opportunity and I could include what
my passion is and see like value in it
like everybody's gotta eat everybody's
got to cook here's a good opportunity I
did the culinary school thing went there
um learned all about cooking I was able
to run cross-country and track Varsity
all four years I just love Athletics
that was always a big part of my family
and uh I just at the end of that I got
credits to go to college and I couldn't
I think it was two years or two I forget
two semesters two years something like
that where those those that culinary
school would count towards College
culinary college didn't sound like a
real college to me it is and looking
back I learned so much but it's real
college but specific for culinary I
actually think that's better but I
wanted that that formal education of You
Know Math Science History English you
know that's what I was used to my whole
life that's what everybody goes to
school for so uh I decided to apply to
Rutgers and doing go to marine biology
becoming marine scientist yeah it's a
good school for that I loved it it was
awesome we did crazy things we sent a
unmanned glider it looks like a cruise
missile that goes up and down in the
ocean uh all the way across the Atlantic
first time ever you know it was a cool
thing to be a part of I didn't even play
like a huge role or anything like I I
helped guide it like once or twice but I
still felt like part of this team that
did something cool and it was really
neat every oceanography class A's like
no problem and it wasn't like I have to
study it was this is going to be awesome
I can't wait to read and and learn I
learned that I do better at that not
reading I hate I shouldn't say hey I
dislike reading I like learning visually
like with the professor or on YouTube
um and that's when I started driving you
know this is college driving around I uh
I drove to school to save money whether
that was a smart a 1996 C4 Corvette no
way yeah so I had an old Deville in a 92
Cadillac DeVille that was technically
like my first car wow and uh got into an
accident somebody ran a red light and my
parents were super proud of me they're
like why not let's get you something I
think we had like a ten thousand dollar
budget I said let's get you something
under 10 grand my dad loves Corvettes I
wanted a Chrysler Crossfire I don't know
if you've ever seen it I remember this
and I did this come out 2003 for
something like that okay and they didn't
run very long but it looked unique it
had the wing that went up on its own or
you press a button like I just love the
quirkiness of stuff like the Coupes it's
yeah it's Unique it's different like how
many do you see around I love that stuff
my dad loves Corvettes one day we went
down to uh to like this this dealership
row we call it and there's a Corvette
for sale and we took for a test drive he
drove and we got back and we were
smiling ear to ear and the salesman's
like like it looks like you guys had fun
and from there I understood what cars
could make you how they could make you
feel something it's not just transport
from A to B it's it's not just looks
it's also a feel and uh so we look for a
Corvette it was my dad's Mission too we
got one and uh beautiful car and I drove
it back and forth to school I saved that
was 10 grand but to to stay one semester
at school was 10 grand did your parents
ever worry about safety with the car no
I was always very responsible like since
second grade we've had a boat that's
like since we love boating so much we've
had a boat and my dad would let me drive
the boat I mean I'm giving him on his
lap and stuff sure but even as I got
older I would go out on a I have this
like 10 foot boat with a little five
horsepower motor it let me go out I
don't know how like if I ever have kids
I don't know how I would let them do
this but they let me go out they trusted
me enough and I would go out on this
little boat and take my own fishing
trips and stuff so I think they knew I'd
be respectful of of the speed be the
power and it's not to say I didn't make
stupid mistakes I feel like we all do it
I spun out once in the rain by accident
because I gave it too much power you
know but I knew that I was given an
amazing opportunity to have like this
car who drives a Corvette to school
right you know and I I love this car I
didn't want to damage it I took so the
care I took for this thing I cleaned it
all the time it's like how I learned a
lot of the detailing stuff I've done
um so I don't think I think they might
have been concerned a little like any
parent but they uh they knew I was
responsible
so but yeah College was great Okay I uh
I worked for the Homeland Department
Homeland Security through Port security
uh with Stevens Institute and that's uh
was it Marcus Brownlee he went he went
there okay so I worked with Homeland
Security there did the port security we
could detect the snapping shrimp versus
a scuba diver so like they wanted that
kind of you know marine biology aspect
of it and then that's when YouTube's
like hey and in the meantime I had like
some videos in the background of me
fishing going on excursions of fishing
trips and doing research and stuff like
that and then a couple of how-to videos
because anytime I had to change the
brakes or something or uh trying to
think change the oil yeah one of the
First videos I did was me going to a
Corvette meet and greet it's just all
the people with Corvettes and that was
like really young everybody else was
older I met one other friend who was
still my friend now who was young and I
just filmed us driving around having a
good time and and uh anytime I need to
fix something like the water pump went
on the Corvette I was like
forms are great that's like how what we
use back then but they're just pictures
they're static I didn't know how this
guy got from ear to here with the
picture and a little text I was like I
could teach people how to go from here
to here in a video really smoothly so no
sorry no you're good I was just gonna
ask for the motivation when you
initially started creating those how-tos
wasn't necessarily to potentially turn
it into a business but it was just
because you couldn't find resources like
that that could accurately and easily
show you how to fix cars yeah it was
like you wanted to help other people
basically exactly I just wanted to help
people I to be this is going to sound
weird I didn't know what subscribers
were I didn't know you could make money
on YouTube I didn't know that was a
thing like it was just I didn't mind
providing free content I thought it was
better than making a forum post trying
to explain this all I was like I'll just
make a video on explaining it so um yeah
I started making those videos and people
started like latching on like hey I like
this and I would go off of views again I
didn't know what subscribers were I knew
what a view was I didn't know what
subscribers were
um so I just go off of hey this got a
lot of views so people obviously need to
learn this so I want to learn this so
what can I do that's similar to this
okay water pump let's do um what did I
do next like oil change I'm like
everybody has to change their oil then
brake job and and these videos were like
quick and dirty you know I didn't have I
had a little Panasonic Lumix camera
um this is before I don't even know if
cell phones were were like you know what
we have now you know we we can't you
couldn't film on a cell phone for sure
yeah
um and I just do my best and try to
teach people and I took my time I was
very slow I talked cautiously and and
like a deeper voice and not as excited
and like I I was very cautious you know
and it just got bigger and bigger and
how and so you would learn from forms so
you go in the forums learn how to do
this yourself
and then if that issue came up again you
would video it correct to a degree and
smoother okay correct yeah like a lot at
this point of my life I knew a lot of
this stuff from boating sure so boat
engines and car engines are the same the
heat exchangers are different one has a
radiator one has a heat exchanger with
salt water going through it otherwise
it's got spark plugs uh it you know it's
got a belt it's got a water pump it's
got all coolant it's got all these
things that cars have it doesn't have
brakes so I had to learn brakes but I
learned that from like my dad and my
dad's friend and so I to afford a boat
because I love fishing my parents knew
that they always always were huge
supporters of everything I did they're
like hey it's gonna be you know we're
cutting it close with the finances with
a boat it's expensive but if we'd
maintain it we winterize it we do all
that stuff give it a try so we got a
smaller boat and my dad would be like
okay here's a spark plug here's how to
do it go do the other seven and I'd be
able to fit in the tight places where
you can't normally reach you know as an
adult and I'd be like doing this and
then my boat neighbors would be like hey
how about a hundred bucks to go do that
to mine and here's like I think this is
like fifth grade now fifth grade me like
okay or here's a tool set oh you and I
have this really nice tool set it's
yours just do the spark plugs just
change the water pump I can't get in
this tight area can you connect these
wires can you can you splice these wires
you know simple things like that that I
would learn and they'd teach me and uh
so I just learned from all over anywhere
I could learn from I would try to learn
from wow yeah and then how long did you
begin doing that like uh what was your
work schedule like when you when would
you have time to film these videos so
it's College it's like studying and I
worked at Pizza on Sundays so like it's
just whenever I I've always I was very
good at studying efficiently so I would
just there's a lot of spare time I don't
know I didn't realize how much spare
time because I was always like oh man I
wish I could just skip college and go
straight into a job because I saw if I
could make money right away then I'd be
better off down the road you could
invest it that's why yeah I followed you
um so I knew that at early age I was
like man I wish I could just get right
into this and just skip all this other
stuff just the stuff that I like want to
learn and need to learn to get a job
done like the marine biology thing this
is right around when the economy was
shot and uh so I was at Rutgers I
graduated they actually accepted me into
their grad program because they liked
what I did with the Outreach the videos
and stuff I took these complex topics
and I made them simple for like the
general public to know and which is
really hard that's one of the hardest
things in science like if you and if you
mess that up you mess up everything for
everybody all the controversy around
global climate change and all this stuff
is because scientists not all of them
know how to explain things so like if
you could take things and explain it in
a way that makes sense and that's real
like it's a lot better for science you
know
um so I went to get my masters and my
sister sent me an email for the New
Jersey State Police and this was
supposed to go to my cousin and I I sent
it to him but I was like oh they have
the Marine Division and I really liked
the Marine Division when I go fishing I
see them out there the Marine police
were always like really nice people they
always waved they take care of you if
like something bad happened you know
they're right there I saw myself I could
do that I could hang in my head you know
this is young naive me I'm like I could
go fishing in my spare time on the boat
you know and realistically I learned
that's not the case but so I applied so
like 25 000 other people it was the
first time they had the application
process open and uh in a long time like
in like 10 years and I got accepted 230
people got accepted wow and I was like
yeah do I continue this Masters and my
my everybody I spoke to was like it's
going to be tough to get a job you're
gonna have to go get your PhD and then
after that you have two more years where
you're doing your post Doc and I'm like
my advisor at Rutgers like you see all
these names there's three jobs here for
Professor you see this this is somebody
that you know you applied to to go to
school their school down in Miami they
want to work here and I had all these
professors that have like 10 20 years of
experience how am I supposed to do that
out of postdoc like how they why are
they going to pick me over somebody who
has crazy years of experience so I'm
like I'm getting stuck in this I love it
I love marine biology if I'm gonna get
stuck here and I'd have to work for the
government or something which isn't
there's nothing wrong with that but it
was not what I wanted to do I wanted to
like become a professor and and have my
own class and do my own research I
didn't want to do like Government
research I was like I'm kind of getting
stuck into an area that
I I didn't really necessarily wanted to
be and I couldn't find an opportunity
and the state police thing came up I got
in I'm very physically fit like doing
the runs no problem I was a
cross-country track person pushed up all
I scored 100 on their physical fitness
tests I must be saying I passed their
background investigation you know no
criminal record none of that stuff the
paperwork I'm not even gonna lie to you
12 inches Stacks it took six months to
do all the paperwork they knew more
about me than I knew about me they're
like hey on this day why did you have
this police interaction and I'd be like
what I don't know like I have to really
think about that oh my God the
background investigator she was super
nice
um she uh she was like you have to
figure it out and then you have to write
an essay on why you have this police
interaction that you didn't list and I
was like
so I like looked at pictures to figure
out dates and like oh that's when I saw
a power line fall and I called the
police to let them know so it was like
simple things like that but they like
they make it they do a couple things
they make it really difficult to weed
out all the people like yeah I'll be a
State Trooper you know no like if you
want it you're gonna have to work for it
and um and so I did all that passed the
psych test past PT pest all that stuff I
got in and it was the most epic
miserable experience of my life so it
was it's worse than the military we had
military guys in there and they're like
what the heck is this they make it
miserable on purpose they want people to
leave and they want to teach you that
you know you follow orders follow all
lawful commands you know and it was
tough It's a sleep away Academy so you
sleep Monday through Friday and then you
have the weekend to
gain your weight back and I'll explain
that in a second and uh and maybe get
some rest and probably not because you
have work that homework you need to do
so you wake up in the morning let's just
say on the first day the first day we
got there woke up in the morning get to
to the academy you get yelled at and
I've never been yelled at like this in
my life what do they yell at you for
anything anything literally like one
guy's hair wasn't sure enough another
guy I'll give you an example yeah you're
supposed to sound off you know when
they're like uh blah blah blah you go
here sir oh you know I'm not going to
yell on the mic but you yell here all uh
here sir as loud as you can it's not
natural to do this one girl was yelling
uh here sir and it sounded like she was
whispering and we're all just like you
can't you have to look stand at
attention you're looking straight and
we're just like what is she doing she's
the trooper who surrounded her like a
swarm of bees
um and they just want to hear you sound
off and I don't know what her problem
was or what she was nervous I don't know
she couldn't yell and that was uh the
last time we saw her you know wow so I'm
good I'm confused this is for uh Marine
policeman correct state troopers so the
state troopers have the aviation they
have the Marine police they have uh
dragon for they have all these it's the
whole entire State uh the police work
for the whole entire State they go
basically where it's really bad or
there's no funding for regular food so
they're going to train you for
everything so that they could be like
we're gonna put you here yeah okay so we
have boxing we have swimming we have all
these different things uh and they put
you in the worst locations like they put
you as far away as possible from your
house so yeah so what's that schedule
like then yeah so so I'll it's
interesting so
um so I go through the academy I'm a
quarter of the way through which felt
like three years it's a six month
Academy and uh we're boxing and they put
you they find your weaknesses mine is
you know I'm pretty skinny like I'm
smaller
um they put me up against a guy who's
like 250
260 pounds you know and and we're boxing
and he gets I know to protect my face
you know duck in and protect from
getting knocked out didn't know to
protect my ribs so he snapped one of my
ribs
um I didn't know it was broken and
there's no time to like they ask any
injuries and I was like oh if I say I
have an injury they're going to send me
to the hospital I'm going to lose time I
could get put on injury leave and I
don't want to do this again so I just
went with it and then a week later I
kept going with it and I was like I
couldn't breathe so we'd be doing so in
the middle of the night they'll pull the
fire alarm it'll be like one o'clock in
the morning and we'll be out doing PT
for hours until it's four or five
o'clock and then have you go back in and
it's freezing cold out you go into a
nice warm room the room just spins when
you're trying to sleep you don't sleep
you get back up and you go and do your
your daily routine and um it was it was
miserable but it taught me I'll explain
that in a second
um and so at one point we're doing
sit-ups for an hour straight and it's
not pop it's not physically possible and
they pick on the weak ones to like hey
like you're not doing any sit-ups so
they'll surround you and and yell at you
and stuff and I was every time I go up
crap back crack crack
and then after that hour we had to do
jumping jacks and I was winded every
time I lift my arms up for the jumping
jack I could feel my ribs it was it was
bad and I was cramping up because I
couldn't breathe and I was like I pushed
this for a week like I boxed again yeah
I swam and and there's a lot more stuff
every day it was just non-stop work so
anyway
long story short any injuries here sir
went to the hospital Rib was was broken
off and they're like yeah you're done
like you have a year of recovery before
you could go back and I was like what
the heck am I going to be doing for a
year and it's funny one of the Troopers
before I left he's like this job it
sucks like it's not fun you see all the
worst stuff you go all the worst calls
it's not like you it made me really
respect the police they're not going
there and and seeing the best stuff
they're seeing the worst stuff and uh he
said I hope you never come back and he's
like I don't mean that in a bad way but
I hope you go find a job on Wall Street
or you know something he said something
like that and uh you know that kind of
stuck with me and in the meantime I was
like what do I do I work at pekko as
like somebody takes care of the
aquariums and I was like I have this
YouTube channel in the background with a
couple videos it's making me like gas
money for the week like 20 bucks a week
or something I said let me double down
on that something I could do from home I
could do with broken ribs and I started
working on the YouTube videos I made two
videos a week now back then it's
completely different if you look at my
old videos you would get it so I made
those videos and it started growing
exponentially and Brands started seeing
that like I remember 3M flew me out to
their headquarters that's big yeah wow
like 3M you know yeah I went from going
from like I don't I couldn't I don't
even know how many subscribers I had
maybe 10 000 because again I didn't
focus on subscribers I just wanted the
views because I wanted to teach as many
people as possible so I didn't have many
subscribers 3M and this is early in
YouTube's infancy you know like people
didn't know it was like a real thing so
I went to 3M they taught me how to do
body work they taught me because they
wanted me to learn their products and
stuff but for me it was like hey it's
sandpaper like it's I could use 3M I
could use any company it's still sanding
body work like it's the same thing so it
was great I got to learn all this stuff
and uh and I kept going to these cool
events I got to drive never came to
fruition but the uh Elio which was like
a three-wheel car that was like got 84
miles a gallon it was really inexpensive
um and it was all these cool things I
was helping a lot of people and the
Troopers I knew some Troopers and bad
things were happening to them some
passed away some got hit by drunk
drivers like a lot of bad things and my
parents knew that I knew that like
friends knew that and they're like hey
maybe you should run with this YouTube
thing you're young enough if it doesn't
work you could always go back to the
police you'd always go back to school or
whatever anything and I always wanted to
be an entrepreneur I always wanted to
open up a restaurant like a Subway or
not like a real restaurant but like a
franchise yeah where I could expand and
grow and and this was my chance for the
American dream to start my own business
and do my own thing so I just started
making videos and I took the the
hardcore of the State Police the you
could never do anything right which is
like the comments uh no sleep which is
like editing non-stop making sure you're
still professional making sure that you
say the right things
um Again State Police recipe that's the
culinary school how to create a recipe
or a formula create a good dish my
videos are a recipe so I was able to
recreate each video even though it was
different oil change brake change and
then the marine biology complex topics
making really simple I put all those
things into one package for everybody
and that's kind of how the channel that
is an incredible story crazy right that
was you're a great Storyteller by the
way nobody knows this except like my
friends and stuff so this is the first
yeah yeah podcast exclusive guys that
that was great you told that so well
like you man where do we even start I'm
curious so much about the the training
academy do they do they pay you for
those six months that you're there how
did you make it the most miserable thing
possible because they want the best of
the best in some ways it hurts them
because like I was smaller like I'm you
know 150 pounds like it's not big for a
trooper and but there's a reason because
like on the highway car blows past you
they they joked about it you know when
they're doing our body mass index thing
you know they they go over and they're
like you're a twig like you're gonna get
blown over by a semi so I get and if
somebody's fighting you as a trooper
you're by yourself backup's 20 minutes
away like there's a lot of scary things
you know so they pick on those
weaknesses on purpose so like it's tough
they make it really difficult and
everybody has a weakness you know and
they find it quickly in the Academy have
you always been really disciplined
because it seems like everything that
you've put your your mind to in the past
whether that be education like Academia
or uh you know the the academy thing it
seems like you've always just worked
extremely hard is that has that always
been the case for you or is that
something that you're always having to
be like mindful of hey I gotta buckle
down I gotta work harder is that just
innately who you are for sure I think
it's a combination of who I am but I
think it's the reason I'm that way is
because of my parents like I saw how
hard my dad worked to allow my mom to
stay home and raise us you know so I saw
him go constantly go to work and he
still made sure he came to our soccer
practices or cross-country meets but he
was working non-stop and he started and
he was at a low position he worked his
way all the way to the top and I saw
that and uh you know they're always the
ones that like pushed me to like be as
good as I can and then I didn't want to
disappoint and at the same time I saw
the value in being trying to be it's not
better than everybody else but trying to
stand out from everybody else not just
working hard but being passionate about
it and uh that was always like I just I
thrived myself I couldn't find myself
sitting around you know I always have to
do something I like to try new things
like I started beekeeping I know nothing
about wow that's cool when did you start
doing that it's this is my second year
now the first year they didn't do so
well but it's a learning experience and
this year hopefully they make it through
the winter I feel like you like anything
with a helmet like you would have to
have heard that yeah you should take up
fencing afterwards hey I actually like
I'd love to try it you know I love
trying to I went to a rodeo the other
day I've never been yeah I just
everything I love learning and
experiencing new things and uh like I
just started Chris fish and it's Chris
fix but for boats and fishing and
specifically for the Marine stuff
there's not a lot of people it's
expensive boats are expensive
so I'm like I could teach people like I
do on chrisfix for fixing their boat
like I put through-hole uh transducers
in which the guy quoted me like 15 grand
for the GPS radar through hole
transduces I'm like I'm not I can't pay
that that's crazy so I bought them
myself and like I know what I need to do
I show how to do it and and teach people
now Raymarine the company the products I
use it's not sponsored or anything like
I bought everything myself they use my
videos to teach their installers I had
the guy from Raymarine tell me I was
like that's pretty cool
should I get any money for that like can
you like you know can I get some free
product can I get a nice flare you know
like night night vision camera or
something yeah I gotta I gotta tell you
I'm I'm like Raymarine I am sponsored by
Lexar
so uh but I I did want to say you have
saved me a ton of money awesome uh I
watched your video on buying a used car
I think when you're buying a Jaguar yeah
right uh which I did not know what to
look for at all you saved me so much
money so if anybody's gonna buy used car
I recommend that video and then when I
was broke like eating 90 Cent Ramen
broke I had no money to get my brakes
changed and um
I did them myself and now that I make a
little bit of money I will never do that
again because it was so sketchy like
with the spring thing do you know what
I'm talking about though yeah for your
drum breaks yeah yeah I get it it was so
sketchy so I'll never do that again so
the question that I'm getting to is are
there anything in cars that you would
tell your fans not to touch themselves
or or is it kind of like the maybe you
need more experience I'm just curious if
there's anything that you think that's
kind of like maybe you shouldn't do that
I mean it's always based on doing what
you're comfortable with you should never
like I was like pushing myself but like
so the rear glass on my mom's Milan
broke and people are like oh you have to
have a glass professional doing I'm like
okay I get why like if you do it wrong
the glass could come out but like if I
follow the processes that like they use
and as long as I'm smart about it like
it'll be fine and it is fine same thing
with brakes people are like hey you're
going to teach somebody how to do brakes
around like I just showed the whole
process it's completely right and like
for people who don't know how to do
brakes they're the ones who are going to
be like oh it's complex you need to you
know you can't do that really not hard
like it's it's simple they fit in place
there's I think there's there's four
bolts you know if you're replacing
rotors there's four bolts what I'm
curious what's your formula for making
videos because I would see your videos
and think there's only so many times you
could teach people how to change the
brakes and like do the common stuff so
yeah how do you how do you keep current
keep a schedule I would imagine you just
you start doing like throwing a Lambo
you're like throwing throw do an oil
change on the Ford GT use use the car
and like hey here's how to do it like no
one has the Ford GT but like the curious
how how it's different maybe I don't
know yeah yeah this is uh this is kind
of like what I dread now because I I
work I I you have 10 million people
watching your every move and you have
people waiting for you to mess up and I
do things that are out of my comfort
rage sometimes they're that are really
complex and since I try to make these
videos relatable to all different cars I
try to cover different things so if I'm
like taking a clutch out and I know okay
well this clutch is going to look
different than the clutch on another car
I'm going to try to explain both but
then there might be this one person who
has this clutch so I try to make it that
you could follow all like whatever car
you have you could get the job done so I
take a week sometimes writing out
outlines making sure I'll go outside and
I'll do the job on the the we're just
gonna make this brakes are easy you do
it your eyes closed at this point so
I'll go and but just as an example I'll
go and do the brakes on the other side
of the car and I'll write everything out
what's the process what did I have a
hard time doing
um even knowing what I'm doing what I
have a hard time doing okay this bolt
was kind of tough so I'm going to teach
people okay they're going to run into
the same issue so how how are they going
to get this off okay use a torch or use
leverage so get a breaker bar what
happens if you break that bolt and you
know it's in there because a lot of
people are afraid to work on their cars
because they're the what ifs what if I
break it so bad that I can't fix it or I
get stuck in the day you could just tow
it you know it costs you a little more
money but it's worth the risk um so I
come out with this really long outline
and
it has to be like it can't be like hours
long this video so I have to narrow it
down I have to pick the right things and
I have to make it as like a recipe I
have to make it easy to follow I can't
just jump from point to point so how do
you do this and then I'll go and film
and I'm bad at speed like right now I
I'm it's easy like yeah this is good
because we're having a conversation but
in the videos I'm not good at speaking
like nobody I'm the same way I say the
same thing multiple times so I get it
right yeah so it's it's hard and one
thing I learned is when you're trying to
worry because I film and do everything
myself I hold the camera and I'll use my
hand gestures to point and all this
stuff pick things up talk about it
you're watching the camera you're
watching for white balance you're
watching for contrast you're watching
for exposure you're watching for Focus
you're also trying to think about what
to say smartly and concise and
efficiently and you're not trying to
talk about things that are out of the
scope of your outline but you already
only have a limited amount of time
otherwise the video could go on for
hours so I mess I take cuts a minute of
my video probably it takes me like
three hours to film at the end of the
day like if you broke it down like
realistically like the intro minute
talking about like planning to or just
like just filming just the filming wow
yeah there's a lot of shots that I have
to put things back to make sure I get
that shot again because it was out of
focus and you can't see because if the
camera's here you're working around the
camera it's hard enough to work on cars
with the space you're given now put this
big DSLR camera with a big mic so you
could hear the stereo noise and and get
your hands behind it or around it it's
impossible you don't realize and I I'm
not realistic I'm like oh I'll get this
done in 20 minutes I'll be able to knock
this out you know my my friend's belt
just started squeaking I'm like I'll
make a video real quick before I go to
SEMA and you know have content to to
edit on the plane and I start filming I
start planning I'm like this let's be
real here this is never gonna happen so
there's a lot it takes a lot of time to
get these shots and just a shot of
getting a belt there's a radiator in the
way how do you how do you go around that
do you disassemble the radiator use a
smaller camera sometimes you have to
disassemble the radiator to do a job
that doesn't require it I don't show
that in the background like you
you don't need to know the radiator is
disassembled so I can put my camera in
there it has nothing to do with the
video of changing your belt but because
I want the viewers to see exactly what
they could see and the process I'll do
that you know and it might be crazy but
that's what I do and then when I make
you make mistakes you know when I make
mistakes now say something wrong or I'll
say uh nut instead of bowl or or
whatever in that case that's simple
enough to fix and post but sometimes
I'll go back out and reshoot it because
I just don't like how it comes out so
this isn't a five paragraph essay that
you constantly produce this is a
dissertation so at the end of the day
this video will be the best the best
video you watched on YouTube for how to
change your whatever it is how to change
your bricks how to change it yeah how do
you top that because I'm sure it's like
me where you've explained a concept but
nobody goes back and watches the old
video so you got to do it again well
that's the good thing you do my old
videos still get hundreds of thousands
of views so that's why these are
dissertations these are like it's it's
the science that you you could go back
to and it's still real it's still
relevant yeah so they'll watch these old
videos and it's still perfectly fine but
how do you keep finding things to fix oh
you have junk cars I have like 12 junk
cars yeah well they're not all junk but
I have 12. yeah like the braid like you
get the brakes you make a few videos of
that like now like you're done with
breaks then you go on to the radiator
you're done with the radio like how many
components are in a car that you could
realistically go and like I'm gonna fix
this today and it's different I have
enough videos for like planned out in my
head for the next five
maybe even 10 years like things just
happen like the glass breaking in my
mom's car yeah that was just freak we my
dad slammed the the trunk glass broke
Boom video I got a flat the other day
Boom video it's a short actually and
I'll post it you know I love that so I'm
gonna see how that does even though like
it was very my Niche you know it's like
how to quickly it's good for us being
quick because that's when you need it
yeah so it's just there's tons of things
I was driving my Hummer to go to the
race with I'm towing more than I
probably should tow with a Hummer and
the transfer case clunks oh my God now
you gotta be kidding me I'm afraid it's
gonna lock up so I got towed home and uh
how to replace the transfer case or how
to rebuild it yeah and speaking of cars
you know my Volvo I mean
um no but I mean I did buy this Volvo
off of gram and uh I I just need to take
the door panel off because I still
haven't paid for that vote you don't
have to air your grievances on the
podcast paid for the vault nope make
your friends pay for cars you give them
oh oh that's the guy that was the
biggest uh comment that we got evidently
they don't pay though so that's uh yeah
yeah so I mean really it was free that's
the other cool thing like a lot of the
cars that you see on my channel that
kind of like disappear I don't sell cars
I have a problem so they either go into
storage or I see somebody who needs a
car that I know and I'm like hey you
know this this Prius is like good Prius
now with the battery I'll say like how
much it's worth on the channel and like
I sold it for that much because that's
how much it's worth and then I'll just
like hey I'll sell it to you for a
dollar you know and and give it to
somebody who actually needs it
um and I find that like it's cool that
I'm able to do that through my YouTube
channel yeah just from the viewers
watching I'm able to help somebody out
in their life and make a difference
um so I help another person with a
Trailblazer like and and it's not like
they can't take care of this okay I can
but having this weight off your chest of
hey I need a new leaser hey I need to
find a used car I know the car is good I
worked on it you know and the car's
bulletproof now so here perfect do you
buy cars then just to fix them up yeah
so that's I feel like that's a lot of
when I get a car that's why I buy it
like I never buy it I haven't bought a
good car except the Hummer but even the
Hummer like when I bought it I didn't
want a project car and I saw the deal of
it you know I'm like oh man this for a
Duramax Swap this was like a really good
price why I went to go see it I'm like
now I know why and I was like I told
myself I called my dad I'm like yeah Dad
this needs too much work on and he's
asking too much and my dad's like you
flew all the way out there just make him
an offer and I told the guy like hey I'm
gonna make you an offer you're not gonna
like it but I'm here my dad told me to
and I was making all these excuses right
and I made them the offer and eventually
he just like and I wouldn't go up I told
myself that's it and eventually he okay
they'll now have another project car but
yeah so I like cheap project cars I
can't tell you about a lot of the new
ones because they haven't come out yet
and they're not coming out I'm very slow
um because I take a lot of time with the
videos so
um but one of them I got really cheap
and it just needs a couple of things and
it's an affordable Supercar like it's
actually affordable like I paid 20 grand
for it can you tell us what car it is I
can't can you bleep it out yes so I got
a
great car yeah that's a deal it's a
death trip yeah that don't those have a
ton of issues usually no the window
regulators don't work that's one of the
main issues so I knew that and they're
expensive they're like I think it was
500 each regulator and the bolt comes
out of the crankshaft and causes issues
and you might need to completely rebuild
the engine and this boat was starting to
come out the owner is like oh I don't
know why the belt is coming off and I'm
like here's a risk I take it either
needs a new engine and the engine is
very unique
um so it would be expensive I'm like do
I take this risk and it took it can't
you just look at the car and be like hey
just give me 10 minutes
a lot of this stuff you have to do in
order to get deals you need to do stuff
that is risky it's risk reward if you
have time to go look at a car so does
some other person they could see it
they're an expert too they could see it
they could take that risk but if you buy
a car from somewhere there's not a lot
of people where not a lot of people are
going to pay this money
it's it's the risk and then you get
shipped to you and the reward is like
this should turn out good like I can't
wait to show everybody so and I have
another car like that as well I could I
could keep going on but the the free car
my neighbor gave me he's like hey I'm
getting rid of this car they wanted like
a hundred bucks to tow it away I'm like
well no don't do that you know it's
worth money in the parts and cats just
give it to this I have a a junkyard that
I'm friendly with they'll pay you like
300 500 bucks for it it's like how about
this why don't you take it and try to
start if not go do that and and the
money's yours I'm like okay I remember
bringing the car back to it's the the
red Honda it's the how to start a free
car
um and he told me all the stuff they
tried to do to it and the mechanics that
he had I guess just didn't diagnose it
right and I was like I'll just show the
steps of doing I'll show my process and
if it works awesome if it doesn't then
I'll show the process of getting rid of
a junk car and and it would be the
timing you know I showed okay check
compression check uh fuel check spark
check air check timing that's pretty
much everything you know and it was just
the timing the the belt skipped a few
teeth and yeah luckily didn't I don't
know if it was interference or not but
luckily it didn't interfere you don't
have like Pistons hitting Valves and
people loved it I think that has like 15
million views or something 10 million
views something like that because it
gives people like that hey I could get a
free car from a neighbor that's a
possibility I could find a junk car
that's inexpensive 500 Trailblazer 300
Del Sol I spent a lot of time looking
for these deals they're real deals
they're real life like
this this is real you know I don't fake
anything and it takes a lot of time to
find these things anybody looking for
cars because your goal is to find
average cars that a lot of people could
afford and show like is there a reason
you don't say you go the hoovies
approach be like I'm gonna buy this 1990
Ferrari whatever you know three four
eight and I'm gonna fix that up and do
cool cars like that like Exotics that
just break down all the time which is
awesome yeah no that's uh I'd say
there's two reasons for that one is if I
brought a Ferrari to my driveway it
would get stolen like having cars out on
my driveway versus having like a nice
garage to keep cars in it'll get stolen
so like that's the first thing so I
can't really have like super nice things
and the second reason is and the more
important reason is
it's not what my viewers are doing you
know my viewers are normal people like
me who are just trying to fix their car
and and they want to learn about cars
they want to buy an affordable car fix
it up uh start a new hobby start a new
passion customize it maybe you know make
it their own go to a car show or just
get to work and it's not it's not people
aren't buying Ferraris like what percent
of the population has a Ferrari you know
versus what percent of the population
has a Honda Civic or a Prius or you know
so were you going to get deals like if
someone's watching this right now and
they want to get a good deal on a good
used car what would you do so I like
using a bunch of different places so I
like using eBay Motors Facebook
Marketplace Craigslist used to be good
but now I think they charge you because
it's it's not good anymore so I don't
even look
um but those two are the the main place
but there's a site called Auto Tempest
that it takes all these sites and you do
one search and it'll search all of them
at once which saves me time because you
know we don't have a lot of time when
we're doing all these YouTube videos so
I'll just constantly search that for
something I'm interested in the Del Sol
people love that thing they're waiting
for of the turbo and I've been not good
about it the whole covet thing messed
stuff up and it was just supposed to be
a joke I was supposed to make a video on
replacing piston return Springs I love
the Honda del Sol so I was like I'll do
it on that car and I found one with a
head gasket leak and uh I was like this
is perfect I'll make the joke video and
then you know I'll fix it then I have a
little Honda to drive around that I love
always love the Del Sol it's quirky it's
it's cool it's Unique it's different
people want to see it get Turbo they
want to see more about it and they just
they fell in love with it a thing that I
thought was a joke where okay it's
piston return Springs April Fool's cool
and they're like oh what else are you
gonna do to it like we know this is a
joke but what else like we want to see
cool stuff yeah so I always see comments
on YouTube videos that say like oh if
this guy's car breaks down he gets
excited so I'm here to ask you is it
true would you get excited if your car
stopped working while you're driving to
a degree so like the Hummer that's my
daily driver
when it broke down and it's not easy to
work on because technically you should
be inside with a lift and and
the parts are expensive and that's like
the one like you're talking about the
Ferrari that's like my version of the
Ferrari that's my dream car it's nobody
has them because they only made like 11
000 and they had all the military ones
but it's not like each one yeah you're
not coming to my channel to learn how to
fix an H1 or at least most people right
there are so a lot of the Homer Gods
I've become friends with them which is
awesome you know but what is that you
know let's just say it's 3 000 people
like none of my videos have 3 000 views
they all have you know millions of you
so people are watching it for for fun
but um
so like that's that's like my version of
the Ferrari and what what was the
question I'm um do you get excited do I
get excited yeah so it breaks down that
that situation no I was not excited it
was like you gotta be kidding me this is
my daily and I that this is the one car
I bought that I didn't want to work on
even though I knew it was kind of a
project car I did all the little things
when the other cars break a little bit
Yeah like when the rear glass broke my
dad's like oh we could call you know the
glass company safely whatever you know
and we called them up and they're like
oh it's gonna be like 500 and we could
get to you in like a week we're like
it's gonna rain so I'm like okay this is
not just my experience this is millions
of people's experience I'm like hold it
let's get the glass from the junkyard
order it on eBay got it through a
junkyard they shipped it to me and uh
and I showed how to fix it and it's a
real life example of like a bad
situation that's good the tire the flat
and the tire so my neighbor just had
work done at her house and they didn't
clean the street very well Nails all
over and uh there's a flat and multiple
cars unfortunately certainly I was like
this is a real life example it's not
just happening to me this is happening
to millions of people let me show you
how to do that so I take a bad situation
and I'm not like excited I'm not like
yeah my car is broken you're just out
there laying nails down here
we go yeah they're like your cars are
always breaking like it's real life you
know like I buy cars that are not well
taken care of before I get them and
that's the whole point that's why
they're so cheap and they break down
until I fix all the parts like my pickup
truck was was like we got it really
cheap and it was not taken care of and
so thing after thing broke and I fixed
each thing and now it's you know it's
good have you ever broke a car on
purpose to make a video about it I
haven't and I don't have the time to do
that people are like hey you just broke
that on purpose oh we I see how oh
there's coolant coming out and one of my
videos are showing how to install a uh
an intake on the Mustang a performance
intake and they think it's some people
not it's it's got to be a small
percentage they're like oh you just you
broke that so you could show that no
coolant's pouring out of there because
it's a common and problem on these the
plastic cracks and I drift the car so it
expedites that and now I'm showing how
to replace it you know so you were
talking about that uh mystery car
earlier that you're like sometimes you
got to take a Gamble and and uh you know
see see if you can get a deal the I
think the average version of that that I
think like a normal person would go
through is have you ever seen like on
carvana that something's like
I don't know I don't know what they call
it but like they say they inspected it
have you ever bought a vehicle on
carvana and actually like looked at it
as somebody who knows what they're
looking at I haven't bought a car in
carvana because their prices would be an
amazing video though right especially
right now common yeah that's true carbon
is having a lot of issues because the
titling I don't know if they solve those
issues many issues the other issue is
that they lose on average 3 200 and
everything they're highly unprofitable
and the only time they've ever made
money was one quarter in 2021 when the
inventory that they bought from 2020
went up in value only time they've ever
been profitable that's interesting see I
I don't know the finance out of that
finances are a dumpster fire it's
amazing so bad
not profitable but still have this multi
Billy is it billion or is it high
Millions like I don't know what their
valuation is now I think it's going to
be zero well yeah yeah so but like like
uber is an Uber not profitable or
something or they haven't they posted
some profit but it's like it's on the
line and think about like everybody uses
Uber like came to Vegas Uber boom that's
the first thing I thought of you know
what Uber am I gonna get so
um but yeah I haven't bought a car from
carvana Mostly because
they're supposed to be good like the
cars are supposed to be inspected
they're supposed to be like when you buy
it from them you're supposed to be
getting a car that is you know you don't
have the Shady dealers like putting
sawdust in the the coolant to try to
cover a head gasket leak
now whether or not I mean they're not
doing it obviously but the cars they're
getting could potentially have those
problems and their their professionals
could miss it um there's so many things
that that you see in the industry that
like it's Shady you know like how do
people do this how how can you how can
you get somebody a car that's this
messed up and no it's gonna fail you
want to hear that tell us about some of
the Shady tricks so the PT Cruiser I
don't like the PT Cruiser my parents got
my sister PT Cruiser for her first car
and uh and it was perfectly fine uh I
didn't do the inspection this is when I
was younger so I didn't do the
inspection or anything
um you know they got it from a you know
reputable used car dealer and
it ran fine for years like it was it was
good for I shouldn't say years it ran
fine for a year and that is a long
enough time where you're like okay it's
not the dealer that did anything wrong
when something goes wrong my parents are
driving on the highway all of a sudden
boom the temperature spikes before my
dad could even get over to pull off car
just the engine melted it overheated wow
the head gasket went well the head
gasket
they used sawdust they didn't even use a
good product they used sawdust to clog
the head gasket and eventually it just
it went now can you prove it was the
dealer that did that no it could have
been the guy who traded into the dealer
or the auctioned the dealer got it from
or whatever and can you say like the
dealer knew about it no but somebody
knew about it along the line somebody
did something like shady that that ended
up hurting somebody down the line you
know luckily it was we were in a SP I
mean we lost money on that car you know
it had to be junked it was there's no by
the time it was used and and uh a year
later and the miles that were put on it
and then the head gasket going I was
like I'm just going to take it apart to
see what went wrong and there's sawdust
everywhere the whole cooling system why
did they do that what does the sawdust
do so it's it it doesn't like don't even
try it they have better products I
actually did a video on Legit products
to save you from a head gasket leak like
my dad's Jag had a head gasket leak and
he needed to use it for work so I was
like we're not replacing the head yes I
don't want to do this you have to drop
the whole engine cradle and it it's like
just three thousand dollars in Parts if
the dealer did it was like six grand so
it's worth more than the car and I was
like I don't want to do this but he's
like well I really like this car I just
want to use it to get through the the
winter so I got a head gasket sealer and
a bottle and they great products now
surprisingly everybody hates them but
for this type of situation the car is
junk you're never going to be able
you're not selling it you're going to
donate it or or for parts of the
junkyard you know and you're not going
to try to sell it and you just want to
try to get a little bit more time out of
it you pour it in the radiator and it
has a liquid glass so when the
combustion gases which are really hot
touch that liquid glass it evaporates
the water from it and leaves behind the
glass wow so it only happens where the
combustion gases are coming out the head
gasket
so it doesn't clog your radiator and I
pulled the radiator out and I showed all
the veins on the clip no clogs it
doesn't clog any of that so the sawdust
what it does is kind of the same the the
coolant the reason why you're losing
coolant is it's going through the head
gasket into the engine so the sawdust is
in there mixed in the coolant and it
builds up more and more the idea is it
builds up more and more than clogs it
doesn't work
like the the gasket sealers in the can
actually today are decent and they
actually do work for that but they get
bad rep because the old ones sting they
eat dealers and and people everybody who
uh who's shady and wants to just like
pass something off that's bad
could do it to their car and I get it
it's not a good thing but if you're like
an honest person you're doing it to try
to help yourself so you have more time
with your car
yeah I think it's great what other
things happen like that so it's a
sawdust one I got a car from an online
salvage auction and this taught me a lot
I was going to do Salvage Auction videos
I was going to teach people like hey
here's a good way to get a really cheap
car that has like a branded title like
Salvage flooded whatever and here's what
the look for here's what you could do it
to fix it and I got this Salvage and
this has never been seen by anybody I
got this Salvage BMW to make this video
and I didn't know any better and this
BMW has been basically passed around and
everybody thinks the same as me oh look
at this thing it's awesome and they get
it and it's been they took um sheet
drywall screws and they screwed them in
to keep the bumper together they welded
the tie rod instead of replacing the tie
rod
um they banged out stuff uh the so it
was a front-end Collision they cut the
airbags and closed the airbag covers
they left it open so like if you look at
the pictures carefully you're like the
airbag looks a little weird but if
you're like looking quickly
you're not seeing it in person and they
cut the airbag out so you can't see so
like a lot of shady things like that I'm
like I can't make these videos because
I'm not I'm not a trained professional
but I see enough cars where I'm like I
could pick these things up and I missed
them so I'm like why not I'm gonna stay
away from this stuff and I called the
company the the salvage company I'm like
listen I know it's as is where is and
it's all my fault but this is dangerous
like this is welded tie rods like you
falsely represented a vehicle that like
it's a sheet metal screws going in and
covered and painted so you can't see it
looks like the Bumper's still on I took
those screws out behind that's a mess so
it's people basically getting these this
junk car and they're passing it around
fixing it up enough so that they could
get their money back you know and wow so
it's like
gives everybody a bad name you know are
there any types of cars you would stay
away from any makes or models or like
certain situations like flooded cars
maybe yeah so I'm a big advocate of dry
go get what you like so like my dad
liked that Jaguar X-Type everybody in
the comments could will be oh you know
the the Jaguar X types of horrible car
it's unreliable and are they right to a
degree maybe this car didn't give us
many problems but it's something he
enjoyed and he had the means to use me
to fix it up you know like so so like
get something you really like the Hummer
Hummer H1 horrible like technically is a
horrible vehicle to Street Drive It's
Made To Go in Humvee in uh tank tracks
off-road 35 miles an hour in a convoy
not 55 miles an hour on a highway uh on
the road you know all that stuff so I'm
a big advocate of uh get a car that you
like that way you know if something does
go wrong whatever you're fixing a car
you like you get to drive you don't life
is so short just enjoy riding driving
what you what you want you know now
flood cars because especially since the
hurricane down in Florida and I was
actually just talking to my my buddy
about this salt water is horrible yeah
like so it's it's hard to tell if the
car's been flooded above the car how
much sometimes it's just like if you hit
the door still sometimes it's like hey
this is a write-off this is we don't
want to it's a flood car you don't know
what's gonna happen in the future water
gets in all the computers on the
floorboards like there could be issues
and how's the deal how's the insurance
company deal with that they just write
it off they say okay it's totaled and
you get that car you could clean out all
the water dry it up and if it runs it
could run fine forever or you might have
an issue five years down the line a year
down the line I don't know if I would
say stay away from it because there's a
price you could get really expensive
cars for cheap for doing that but just
know the risk reward no like hey I'm
buying this thing there's a chance it's
not what I expect it's not like buying a
a new car where it's warrantied and all
that stuff have a little confidence in
your abilities and just do what makes
sense like know the don't be there's no
good deals like know that they're I
shouldn't say there's no good deals when
you have a good deal is a reason let's
put it that way sure so know that
there's that situation and you could
fall into that the bad part of it and
have a problem and I mean you've worked
on so many cars I'm sure you've probably
noticed a pattern with certain makes
though it's like oh unlike you know a
Ford Focus or whatever this tends to go
wrong or this the Ford Focus tends to
have more problems than like a Toyota
Camry or Corolla is there any like
pattern that you recognize among certain
makes where you know stuff tends to go
wrong more so with those cars let's say
someone wants to buy a used car they
don't know anything about the seller
they don't know anything about anything
right but they just see a Camry and a
Ford Focus yeah would you lean them in
no one of the two directions go test
drive it see which one you like better
which one do you think looks better
um and I mean both of those are economy
cars so like they're every car has its
problems every single one
every single car so like Toyota
everybody says Toyota is so great they
don't break down they do just like every
other car they do have great reliability
but when they do break down those parts
Toyota parts are expensive
I just uh rebuilt is a marine engine
it's Yanmar but it's a division of you
know Toyota or whatever they use Toyota
parts the parts are crazy it's like
insanely expensive compared to a Ford
part where they they have so many and
they're really not that expensive I
really honestly truly believe that you
should drive stuff that you that you
want to drive and um I'll I'll stick to
that but yeah like every car so like
when you're looking to buy a car it's
good to go and type in like common
problems for XYZ your year make and
model I could use let's use the Mustang
the drifting for example very common
issue with that the odometer stops
working because the little gear in there
gets stripped out and you don't know the
real mileage and if you're test driving
the car you don't notice it not going up
could have 500 000 miles on that car and
it says 120. so that's like a common
problem that basically affects them all
the it I was talking about the uh air
intake has the coolant going through it
and it leaks because it's plastic it
cracks
very common problem with those
um the bushings in the rear suspension
they go bad over time and you know you
could have bad suspension problems and
and easy to fix but another common
problem that's different than if you're
looking at a minivan or something you
know so try to learn those problems by
just doing some quick research type in
the year make and model and um and on
YouTube and something to see if like
you're making model fix and then you're
you're missing a keyword what are you
fixing and those keywords will hopefully
like fill in like
radiator fulfilling okay well this has a
guy will be like oh there's a radiator
problem on these cars so let me show you
how to fix it so you learn that what are
your thoughts right now on the used car
market used car market is I think a big
bubble I think it's gonna so I'm not a
finance guy and I could be completely
wrong I feel like it's like a 2008
bubble with a housing I feel like it's
similar with the used cars people are
paying 20 30 100 000 over MSRP depending
on what it is I saw the new what was it
super oh no the the Nissan the the 400.
oh yeah the Z yeah it was like 49 000
sticker and they wanted a hundred and
five dealer markup you know what
someone's paying it yeah well those
people yeah like no offense to them but
they're part of the reason this is a
problem I love the free market and and I
love the like it to self-regulate but
like money was pumped into our economy
and now people have extra money to spend
and now they're they're using this money
in in bad ways and poor decision ways so
they're buying these cars over sticker
you should never pay over MSRP I I could
get at MSRP for every single car out
there or less well I shouldn't say every
single car every normal car out there
sports cars and limited edition things
like every you'll get a a Ford an F-150
or something and the guy's like oh we
have a price markup because of the uh
whatever it is whatever their excuses
Pinstripes you know they
you can get that at MSRP you go find
somewhere else spend a few minutes to go
shopping there are dealers that will do
only MSRP and I think people paying more
than that the car is worth MSRP after
you take a car off the lot it's worth
less right now no but economy is going
to simmer down and then it will be worth
less I think it's crazy how it's become
so normalized now to drive a car and
then expect to sell it for more
I remember well I'm not we all remember
driving yeah the good old days when like
it became Common Sense the car would
immediately lose 20 of its value as soon
as you drive it off the lawn and now
it's not the case it's so odd but I was
doing research for a video that I had
posting this week and BMW said that
they're going to be producing less to
keep their price point the same they
don't want to make more and have their
cars drop in price anymore Tesla is a
great example of this of just like a
build to order and they're increasing
the cost of autopilot to keep those used
cars from hitting the market at a lower
price and impacting sales Ford even came
out and said that they want to now do a
build to order model or they're looking
into it where customers would be able to
purchase cars direct now that might just
be the electric cars for right now but
that's how they want to move it always
starts somewhere yeah but Mercedes also
chimed in and said something similar
that they want to focus more on the
luxury Market which means they want to
keep their prices the same so I think
all these auto manufacturers are really
realizing if people are paying this
price we would be stupid to make more
and drive the price down we may as well
make less charge more we have higher
profit we'll have the same profit
margins making less cars less overhead
yeah I mean as the manufacturer that
kind of makes sense it does and there's
no proof like they're saying oh it's
it's uh you know because we can't get
chips and stuff like that which is
probably true yes there's no proof
though like they it's not like they're
there's a way we could audit that and
see yeah I've heard stories I've heard
stories that a lot of the dealers are
keeping cars on the sidelines to make it
look like they're you know they don't
have inventory to make you pay more I've
but who knows uh yeah the chip shortage
just seem to be that the main narrative
right now is that there's not a big
enough supply of chips they can't make
as many cars as there is demand but even
for the used cars I mean it's just it's
it's extended throughout everything
right now I find that as like job
security because once they start doing
this only like really wealthy people are
gonna be able to afford new cars yeah
they're gonna just go up and value
somewhere like getting a new car right
now think about it the F-150 or it was
an F450 or 350 I pulled up and uh that
was dropped off in that car is like 120
Grand that's the house I know in some
states
like yeah that's a house the issue I
think right now is with the loans that
it's so easy to get an auto loan yep and
unlike a house where they do an
appraisal and they have someone
physically go and check out the house do
the comps it doesn't exist with cars
it's just what price are you paying
we'll give you 150 percent of that to
account for tax and registration license
and fees here you go enjoy and there's
very little oversight on loans exactly
that's what I said Thank you like 2008.
I think so that's because that's what
happened in 2008 with the housing right
correct me if I'm wrong yeah people are
getting loans that they probably
shouldn't have gotten and then the
market crashed yeah what's even crazier
is that uh I don't know the exact
statistics I believe it was 20 of people
admitted to lying on their car loan
application to get the card that they
wanted another one was that and maybe
correct me Alex because you edited the
video but there was another part where I
think it was only 30 of the loans that
were submitted were actually verified so
you have a big portion that were never
verified and you have one in five people
lying on their application think of how
easy it is just to write because they
don't do income checks right a hundred
thousand instead of 80 get the car that
you want I think what's happening is
that uh it's kind of going towards that
area where people are no longer looking
at the price of the car and they're
looking at the monthly payment and so
when Banks start offering these 86
months ridiculous car loans it's like
well you know who cares because you know
my payments only only seven hundred
dollars like yeah you know so you you
can't afford that though yeah so that
was that was another crazy thing is that
the average car payment is now just over
700 a month the average loan I think
it's 76 months is 70 able the average
loan is 72 months there you go the
average person 72 months but the average
person uh gets a new car at 71.6 months
so like right as they're about to pay
off the car they sell the car roll it
into another 72 month loan and start the
process over again they never fully
owned the car
crazy is that it's interesting that is
insane yeah insane yeah
holy cow I mean I've only ever had old
old cars my entire life yeah same I've
never had a new car never you've never
bought a new car yeah so I'm a believer
of using your skills Tesla was was the
only car that I bought new what about
the well you least I guess the Mercedes
right that was a sublease that was a sub
that was a sub please
yeah because the guy put like five
thousand dollars down and then he had 18
months left of his lease it was
swapalease.com
uh and so I just picked up this guy's
deal and he had pre-paid for the
maintenance so like I got all of this
stuff free I think my payment was
oh gosh I think it's 430 a month or
something like that but uh it was like a
somewhat brand new C-Class and it was
like the C-Class with the sport or
whatever it was but that was a great car
it's cool getting deals even if it's
something simple like that I know
there's something more special about the
car when you get it as a deal versus
yeah you get ripped off I don't know how
if I got ripped off I would I don't know
if resents the right word but I hate my
car because like I got one on me you
know like somebody somebody ripped me
off with this thing every time I see
that car I knew they got me like so I
think getting the deals is like that's
like what keeps me happy with my cars
well you'll be able to get good deals uh
because in the video that I'm posting it
was found that subcompact car prices
have fallen 3.6 week over a week
interesting and they're continuing to go
down the only category that did not go
down a price were the sports and luxury
Vehicles this is exactly what happened
how I remember in 2008 the Hummer came
out the H2 and H3 and they were gas
guzzlers and everybody's like has all
this money Hummer just came out the EV
Hummer came out now you know uh what you
just explained now and all this is it's
just like mirroring what I saw in 2008
so I mean it's just things I'm
connecting again people saw the Hummer
as a good tax write-off because if it's
weight yeah yeah over six thousand
pounds or six thousand pounds so that
had it was funny in La they called it
the real estate agent car because all
the Realtors were buying the car for the
write-off but you also have to be able
to afford the fuel that's true too and
the maintenance and this is true yeah so
and then when things go sour what's the
first thing you get rid of your luxuries
like your boats your luxury cars yeah uh
and then like Hummer to me is a luxury
car you know you get rid of all these
luxury things in the market Falls that
Homer that I drove they gave me the uh
the new H1 the oh not each one the
Hummer EV part of me really wants that
car and three seconds zero to sixty nine
thousand pounds I thought it was 2.9 or
it might even be 2.9 beat three seconds
is there a party that would buy that
yeah not for the price right now they're
selling about 200 Grand well you well I
don't know what you could like it never
go for like I said never go above MSRP
but MSRP is like 115. yeah even at that
price like I just think it's such a cool
looking car I I don't like Cosmetics
look yeah and the crack crab walk is
really neat it's such a gimmick the crab
walk is useless I use it off-road it's
completely useless but the rear steer
after having rear steer and taking it
off-road it lets you make these turning
the these the Turning race is insane it
lets you go really tight and you don't
have to back up and make K turns like my
Hummer offer I took in the same spot my
Hummer in this Hummer I have to make a k
turn to go around a certain area this
thing rear steers automatically you go
right around crab walk I'll be honest
with you I mean there might be a way to
use it that like it's it's useful for
yeah it's just a gimmick it's cool it's
really cool looking I love the uh the
the range that you could get on a car of
that size to get what was it like 250
miles I think it's three something three
don't let that fool you because the one
downside was it was like 80 bucks to
fill up and also at a home charger like
120 volt it took forever to charge
really yeah you would have to definitely
get like so I used 150 I think they go
by amp hours or amps or or I don't know
exactly what the charges go by I I know
150 is real is pretty high
um and it for 20 minutes it went up
70 miles I think
uh and then but if you use a home
charger it could take like a day to
fully charge it maybe even longer I
don't I hate it 240 volt uh no 120 volt
so like a normal home charge yeah you
know if you if that's not bad I mean
because I was charging my model 3 at
just with an extension cord and I just
plugged it in it got five miles uh per
hour
I didn't care I rarely Drive anyway so
it's always charged see but for us we
work from home like and you have other
vehicles but for somebody who needs to
get back and forth to work oh yeah and
they have to rely on this like I don't
know it's just they're pushing it too
fast and they're forcing it instead of
like like making it like a another
decision we could make so that's just it
bothers me because they're like hey
we're not making gas cars anymore we're
Banning them like that that hurts like
guest cars it's cool like the you see
the new Gymkhana can block he used the
electric car it was awesome it was
really crazy cool he went through Vegas
to like he has this electric Audi it was
really neat but there it was just
missing and they did a great job with
the production they did a great job with
the stunts it was just missing the noise
it's not like an electric car which is I
guess kind of cool but it's missing that
bro and like the the flashes and the
bangs and you know what's going on in
there it's like yeah it's like organized
chaos and in the engine and like I don't
know I guess that's just us growing up
with that maybe the new generation
doesn't I think I think it's probably
just what you're used to something like
I buy cars based on how the exhaust
sounds you know like it doesn't sound
really cool or is it like kind of lame
yeah well do you think that's going to
make gas powered cars more expensive
just like in terms of like a like a this
is one of the few gas powered cars left
like the old Ferraris and being like a
naturally aspirated car
yeah yeah yeah yeah stick shift is now
more expensive instead of cheaper I I
don't know I honestly don't know Jay
Leno said that he thinks it's gonna be
like the horse everybody used horses and
then finally they came out the car but
horses now are like a luxury you know
they're expensive
um whereas horses back then were a
necessity so it wasn't expensive so
you're on to something I think initially
no
um but eventually probably yeah what do
you think about the move towards
automatics and egaris versus Manual of
course trying to bring it back for
manual I like just the Innovation like
it's all it's all good I personally like
stick but I get it like if you've been
in a stick car and you're in traffic
it's miserable yeah like especially if
you have like a performance clutch or
something thing but at the same time if
you're on the racetrack if you're
drifting you need to stay car you know
like that's just something that you
really want it's all personal preference
like if it stinks because I know mass
production they want to bring the prices
down as much as possible but I wish they
could always give that option so that
like this is going to be my fun car so I
want it stick this is going to be my
daily driver so I want it automatic I
don't know yeah one thing you mentioned
earlier that surprised me you were
mentioning editing your videos you edit
yourself yes I do every so everything my
channel is done by me except any
contracts I make I have a lawyer I don't
know the legal Mumble jumbo although
I've gotten pretty good at it because
I've seen enough but I always like to be
extra careful and like what there's
there's no competes and there's all this
and that I like uh I like making sure
I'm like handshake is like a real thing
you know I'm honest in to my word so
what's your team look like just you and
a lawyer well the lawyer isn't really on
my team she's just somebody I hire when
I have stuff yeah that I need legal
things done
um so say that's me that's incredible
that's one of the few people I think
that that could get to we'll round up
we'll say 10 million subscribers on
their own yeah very few people have done
that without without you know a team
behind them it's cool it's it's uh it
goes to show you what you could do in in
your driveway at home with common hand
tools by yourself and do you do the
audio in real time as you're fixing up
the car or is it something that you put
in afterwards I've always wondered I've
wondered that so much so many people do
and like I answered so I answered four
hours of comments every day like that's
I like to help people and so for hours
it's four hours wow every day every day
what what hour to what hour sometimes
it's sporadic most of the time when I
wake up it's like an hour like I'll I'll
get right up brush my teeth eat some
breakfast
or do you do like top comments newest if
people want to get their comment
responded to how do they do it it's just
they just have to comment a lot right
throughout the day yeah I mean there is
I didn't like doing this but this is
what people want me to do you could like
pay for the membership thing I made it
99 cents as cheap as possible so that
your comment comes to the top so I could
get it and the reason I did that is
because that's the only way you could
like guarantee I see it otherwise
I mean it's like how many comments a
second do you get right you know
um so I I do try to answer four hours a
day and I can't answer all of them a lot
yeah but it's important because this is
like part of like the learning process
it's like going to a class with your
professor and you can't ask questions
those are the worst classes but if you
have a question you could raise your
hand and they can help you that's great
I see a lot of similarities between you
and Graham yeah Chris are you like
afraid that you know bringing in an
editor somebody to help is going to
change the content or change how you
know maybe people perceive it maybe they
don't know your style or or is there a
different hesitation if I could bring in
an editor I'd do it in a second I've had
multiple people try to edit my videos
the way I film people hate me so going
back to the audio question
yes it's done while I film but it's also
done post sometimes so like if you want
to hear
I shouldn't even say post it's done
right after I fix it let's just say
we're unscrewing a bolt I want you to
hear that that that ratchet noise but if
I'm talking while I'm ratcheting
it it goes over that you don't hear both
or you hear like a mix of it so they get
that really crisp sound a ratchet away
you hear you know the ratcheting noise I
won't say anything and then right after
that I'll take the bolt out and you'll
hear the bolt come out like that's how
quiet it is and then I'll flip the mic
around and say okay now we're going to
use a 16 millimeter sock well I don't
know I picked 16. now we used a 17
millimeter socket and we're gonna break
this loose and you know that snap I'll
stop the audio you'll hear that snap of
the bolt breaking loose and we're going
to remove this the rest of the way and
you'll hear the ratchet so now you have
this really crisp audio and is it extra
work yes a lot like it it like triples
the editing time and then if there's
like a mistake I'll go over and do
voiceover like sometimes I just say
things I'm like why am I dumb like why
how how did I not catch that I said some
I said nut instead of Bolt like what the
heck and I'll go back to where I was at
the car and I'll put the mic there if
the wheel was off I'd take the wheel off
so I have the same exact audio and uh
and I would try to mimic that audio and
if it works great if not I'll reshoot
that whole thing it's so funny I do the
exact same thing uh for b-roll uh when I
could just speak I'll sit in the exact
same spot put the curtains in the exact
same way say it yep can't tell the mic
facing the same everything everything is
the same I know that's one of your
concerns yeah you know you guys are like
oh you know it might sound a little bit
different for the different bikes and
like we want to make sure it sounds real
crisp and I totally get that and uh so
hopefully you know it doesn't mess
things up too much that is crazy about
the comments because I answered every
single comment they're like 99.99 of
comments until I hit a million
subscribers same same exact thing yeah
it was actually here in Vegas I couldn't
keep it my first trip in Vegas I
couldn't keep up that was the first time
I was like oh man I went to SEMA I'm
like I'm answering comments before I go
to SEMA and it's taking so much time
like this is the first time this is it
that is great yeah I would wake up in
the morning and I wouldn't get out of
bed until all the comments were answered
from the night prior and then I'd go to
bed but not go to sleep until I answered
all the comments and it would be like I
must it must have been about four to
five hours a day that I was spending
just answering comments and I just
wanted to keep it up until I hit a
million and then I went down to an hour
a day after that just answering comments
that's good good answers but even now um
every time I post a video for the first
hour after posting I'm there just
answering comments it's always Alex and
I people are floored they're like they
think it's a bot or if they think I pay
someone else to answer but little do
they know it's me and Alex sitting and
Alex comments from his own account but
I'm sitting on the couch answering
comments and everyone's like this is
Graham Graham wouldn't I'm like yeah
it's me yeah actually answering comments
yeah and all the platforms yeah it's a
lot of work even DMs like sometimes I
tell people hey because on YouTube
there's no way to oh my car mix is like
blah blah blah blah sound yeah and they
just type it out there's no way to hear
that sound but hey DM me on Instagram
real quick
the video I'll try to listen and and
diagnose it you know it's not always
possible but I try you know yeah so but
that's good I'm glad I'm not the only
one no I've never met anyone else who's
really who's gotten to your point
without help I think strad man is
another example he had an editor and uh
camera guy briefly I think for what
eight months to a year but now it's just
him yeah and I don't think he has any
other plans of changing it and I think
that's what keeps it like really homey
and authentic it's just that it's just
like him in a camera he's the one that's
editing he knows kind of sense of humor
in there something personal about it you
could give Two Chefs the same recipe and
it would taste different yeah so like
you I could give the footage and give it
to I could edit it and I have an editor
edit it it'd be completely different
even if they try to mimic your style and
stuff because I've tried it I've I have
a file on my my Google Drive that when
people email me and say hey I want to
edit for you I could do it I know I can
I hope I hope they can I re like I I
would love to have a life because right
now I just work 16 hours a day seven
days a week what's your schedule like
Now work like walk us through like an
average day what would what would that
look like sure I wake up uh I'll get
some breakfast I'll answer comments uh
you know brush your teeth that's simple
stuff go right to whatever I'm doing
let's just say I'm planning a video go
right to my computer and start whatever
I need to do to plan for that video
right now line
um go through it in my head whatever it
is and let's just say we're filming that
right that day right I'll set everything
up set all the cars up so I work in a
driveway I work outside hopefully the
guy next door isn't doing the lawn next
door is not a problem across the street
the problem because he blows his leaves
like a lot and you can't have that ring
yeah I hate that all day and then also
the leaves and the fumes it smells so
bad to leave the dust gets all over so
I'll move the cars around I'll set
everything up make sure like the
lighting is good I have these big uh
what they call soffits the the lighting
um soft boxes soft boxes yeah I have
that set up and I'll get the tools set
up and I'll run through everything and
start writing things down make sure okay
I have this I have this I got the intro
ready let's shoot the intro today and
I'll shoot the intro and I'll take a
million Cuts I'll make sure the tools
are like perfectly set up I say
everything efficiently smoothly I'll go
in and edit it and be like I got that
Intro by the time I'm done doing that
it's uh usually I don't break for lunch
I kind of just work through that it's
kind of near dinner time I'll eat dinner
and then after dinner I'll go back to my
my office my whatever and I'll work on
the computer edit plan for the next day
answer comments go to sleep repeat
is there a reason you don't have a
warehouse or something so that you could
prevent sound distractions it's it's so
tempting but I really feel like people
seeing me do these
what they think is complex things it's
just a car but what they see is complex
things done in my driveway at home with
common hand tools I try not to use power
tools but I mean more and more people
are getting power tools today but I try
not to not not to use specialized tools
unless you can rent it for free or it's
like a complete necessity you could like
you see me doing this at home in my
driveway like it's it's no no lifts jack
stands and Jacks like everybody if
you're working on a car that's the bare
minimum what I'm doing is like the bare
minimum so you could do it yourself
it's it's it stinks though because you
can't make videos quickly yeah and that
neighbor's out there I can't work how do
you balance that with the social life or
do you do you just accept that like hey
right now I gotta grind this is my time
to head down for sure
um so you I grind that's just like how
I've always been and I I do take like
okay my friends say let's go fishing
today I'm like today we're going fishing
and that's kind of why I started Chris
fish because I felt bad fish and this is
how bad it got or how bad it still is I
felt bad fishing because I'm not making
the YouTube videos and because I read
the comments yeah they're like oh what
the heck's taking so long I'm like I'm
out fishing today and I see what the
heck's taking so long and I'm like I owe
it to them to like not go fishing and
just continue to work on this project
even though it's gonna you know it's
just constant work and it's not healthy
so I'm like oh if I make a fishing video
channel then I can video as I I just
made more work for myself really but I
try to like come up with a reason to
like to monetize go fishing you know
that's funny that's why I started the
Graham Stefan after hours originally I'm
like Hey listen we work we could just
film it yeah yeah we could film
ourselves making money and make more and
so we just did that that was the so we
created this to family but it was easier
when Jack was looking here just make
more work for yourself it was you don't
think about it you're like oh we're just
I'll go fishing yeah in the moment we
thought it was I mean we were being
productive they're great videos it's fun
by the way to look back at those videos
oh yeah because it's a trip because now
those videos are like a year and a half
old good look back at what we were doing
that day a year and a half ago and
they're so well done like the amount of
work that went into making a silly
little Vlog but like Alex has been so
long editing those things yeah remember
those Alex nude those were my babies
like I you did a great job but you know
what though I feel like all that was
part of like a lead up to doing what I'm
doing now you know I feel like without
that everything would be different
because
I there were some pretty bad edits and
there was some pretty good edits and I
feel like it all it all was a learning
experience yeah and the first video was
edited by uh we had this guy Colby come
in and he edited the first one then Alex
I think edited the second one and you
see the difference between Styles too
it's like the same content but different
editing totally different like senses of
humor we're putting that but uh yeah we
just created way more work yeah but we
kept it up for a year did a full year of
uh Vlogs once a week hey it's good to
try stuff you know it's always worth
giving something a try and see what
happens yeah otherwise you'll never know
I have a question to ask man if we came
here yeah I opened the door for you and
and you're wearing that helmet like
I'm just curious like I just really want
to see what's underneath like is that
yeah is that is that possible like just
for me or us you know what
just for you guys really okay gosh it's
really yes we have to be we have some
contracts I'll have you guys something
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cool let's see take the helmet off oh my
gosh
suspense
no oh my gosh seriously right oh whoa
you're so handsome Jack calm down man
wow wow I cannot believe what I'm seeing
with my own eyes so now you guys know
the reason why yeah wow
let's keep the ladies away
yeah yeah
how can people find a mechanic that they
can trust and do you trust mechanics
that's a great question I have okay this
is gonna be tough for me because I've
never used a mechanic I kind of pride
myself on that oh wow so like I'll try
to fix everything I mean I used like
tire change places I think the best way
to do it is Word of Mouth like who do
your friends use and do you like them do
they like them and then you just go that
way uh that's probably the best way to
go about it because they're going to be
completely honest you know and and what
about when you go to get an oil have you
gotten an oil change
um no there we go that's crazy okay so
when people go to get oil changes a lot
of the times you go for the oil and they
say oh this is broken this is broken
this is broken this like literally
create a list of 10 things that you
apparently need to fix ASAP on your car
and when you say when you say well is my
car gonna break if I don't fix this
stuff they always go you know
anything every single time I get an oil
change so I like to believe that most
people are going to be like be good
people you know and they they see like
hey a boot is ripped on a ball joint and
they're like hey
you might need a new ball joint or you
see the boots ripped on an axle and
they're like you know you could get dirt
and you're gonna need a new axle or at
least replace the axle boot and they see
these things and and
doesn't need to be changed right there
if you could yeah if it's hard to afford
it like doesn't nah not necessarily but
they're gonna their job is to point out
anything they could see that is is
potentially wrong and in your head like
you want to have it's not the space
shuttle but you want to have everything
running perfect that way you don't get
stranded you know but do you need to
replace every like I drift I I race a
lemons BMW like we we do stuff that's
like we make it work you know
so I've seen I've run on cars on tires
I've drifted on tires that have had
um bugs in them they drift just fine and
some people are like oh once you get a
plug you should really you know get it
patched inside I've run plugs forever
and like realistically no it's fine but
it's hard to answer it that's why it's
important to find somebody that you
could trust you know somebody that like
has great reviews from your friends and
family because those are people are
going to be honest with you but I mean
the reason why I made my channel was
because
if you don't know those things you don't
know how to fix your own car you have to
rely on somebody else and It Automotive
has a bad rep for you never know getting
taken advantage I went to Valvoline that
I got my oil done there and they did my
transmission fluid and then I went back
you know four months or so later to go
get my oil done again and the person
checks my transmission fluid as they
usually do and he's all yo this is so
overfilled and I was like well what does
that mean because I have no idea like if
they say my transmission fluid is over I
don't know if that's bad or anything he
said oh it's pretty bad and I'm there
and I'm texting my friend who like Sells
Cars he like buys cars cheap and then
fixes them up and resells I'm like do I
need to fix it's lucky you know I'm like
do I need to fix this this problem he's
like ah you're probably fine I'm like
okay yeah so it's just it's a common
thing it just happens yeah so like a
overfilled transmission it could cause
parts to have too much pressure inside
low SEALS or like overfilled oil the the
bottom of the rod could hit the oil and
create Bubbles and the bubbles get
sucked up now a bubble isn't oil it's
air so it's not protecting the
components that are no good that are
need to be protected you know so like
there's there's it's like anything else
there's truth to to everything and
there's also people who are not just not
not good people and trying to take
advantage of you that's why again super
important to find people you trust
because at least you hope they don't
take advantage of you what do you think
is the ugliest car
ugliest car gotta be the Aztec you know
like that doesn't do is that the one
that uh from Breaking Bad yeah yeah yeah
yeah I have to think about that I don't
know maybe I'll put that down in the
comments how's that sound sure okay I'm
I'm so sorry but I think a PT Cruiser is
just that no don't be sorry I thought
the same thing or my parents got it I
was like no it looks it looks like a an
insect is what it kind of looks like
yeah you know the key is soul I don't
really that's yeah that's not a good one
yeah that's I would agree with that kind
of like to have this old look but I also
like the Hummer H1 like I like that I
like that I like the Hummer H1 it's just
I don't like that one window that kind
of Curves around and bothers me yeah I
get that I hated the look of the uh The
Pagani
I should never say never because I'm a
really hard worker but like you could do
it a few good Investments you watch the
main she subscribe to Graham Stefan make
a few good Investments over a long
enough period and uh there you go thank
you so much man of course thank you for
having me this is great first podcast
ever you go first podcast ever we feel
honored this was a great episode I
really appreciate that you're a
fantastic Storyteller thank you very
much thank you any message you want to
impart on our viewers before we close it
off uh no just always so you heard my
story of how I kind of got started doing
my thing and I think like always when
you have something that comes up when
you're when you're going to school and
you have this opportunity as long as you
can find some interest in it take that
opportunity even if it's not exactly
what you want worst case scenario you
learn something new and you fall back
and you start doing something else so
always take your opportunity and not
just working hard but being passionate
about it that's important because
everybody works hard like no matter I
shouldn't say everybody most people will
work hard but not everybody will be
passionate about it and that's where you
differentiate yourself perfect thank you
so much appreciate it no problem